[Música]
boa tarde você a gente está bom né tudo
bem com vocês é o seguinte eu pra quem
não me conhece meu nome é renato roberto
e eu tenho um canal no youtube que se
chama nerd show
só que eu queria falar um pouco pra você
sobre o que muita gente tem um vão dizer
se um certo preconceito com o pessoal
que trabalha com o youtube
o que você já deve pensar mais no
youtube youtube é aquele cara o peso da
pessoa que fica jogando geleião no outro
eu que sou do tempo da geléia gente
slime é uma coisa do passado entendeu
mas eu queria mostrar pra vocês um pouco
da da história como funciona e tentar
vão dizer se inspirar vocês não só não
só falar sobre o youtube em si mas um
pouco assim de pensar um pouco fora da
caixa de como tornar as coisas num
negócio então eu queria mostrar a vocês
além da parte divertida do youtube né
mostrar um pouco sobre a parte
profissional do negócio como funciona e
talvez levem isso por algum outro ramo
que não tenha nada a ver com o youtube
bom mas quem é esse cara é bom já falei
com vocês em meu nome é renato e eu
sempre desde pequeno é engraçado falar
isso mas eu falava com minha mãe mãe não
quero trabalhar pra ninguém
eu quero ter meu próprio negócio o
catatau zinho não sabe nem quem era nada
vendo cavaleiros do zodíaco na televisão
fazer mãe não quero ter um emprego
normal eu quero trabalhar sozinho porque
meu pai ele é serralheiro ele trabalhava
sozinho achava muito legal
então desde muito cedo eu tive essa
idéia de tentar empreender sabe é esse
foi o primeiro vídeo que eu fiz pelo
youtube
assim vocês verem a qualidade né
qualquer história desse desse vídeo a
gente sai um dia do macdonald's depois
de pedir exatamente 15 hambúrgueres
negócio para essas duas vezes
o negócio envolve primeiro recorde mas a
gente pensou assim não fazer alguma
coisa pro youtube é na verdade a gente
queria fazer um podcast que o podcast em
2010 eu comecei com o youtube em 2010
lá na época estava começando a bomba
d'água podcast um jovem nerd no segundo
mas não pode querer também chegou na
hora que alguém são não sabe o podcast
eu sempre o simples que falar isso não
se pode queixar um programa de rádio
online
bom tudo bem vamos fazer um podcast ramo
pegou o microfone branco do windows pêgo
eu não sei da onde então vão abrir a
webcam é bom conviver nesse negócio
youtube que que tá rolando agora bom
a minha formação vamos dizer assim nunca
foi muito ortodoxos é que a gente pode
dizer assim eu sempre fui o como diz o
nome do meu canal eu sou nerd show que a
idéia era que tivessem um show do nerd
então eu sinto que eu quiser falar eu
falo mas basicamente a gente se baseia
mais nos entretenimentos nos anos 90
curiosidade sobre filmes séries e tudo
mais
bom é desde pequena sempre nerdzinho da
turma aquele que sentava atrás porque
era muito grande na verdade eu consegui
sentar na primeira carteira e tudo mais
mas eu sempre queria eu vi as coisas de
uma forma diferente assim
só que a educação formal assim dizer
você tem que entender tudo o que está no
livro de histórias em tudo o que está no
livro é real eu sempre fui muito
questionador
com isso eu sempre acreditei que a gente
podia fazer é entender sobre várias
coisas e tudo que você conseguir se
estudar e te agregar em alguma coisa em
outra coisa que não tinha nada a ver
resumindo eu fazia muitos cursos por
exemplo eu que nem falou já eu não sei
se ele falou eu fiz ginástica olímpica
eu sei lá eu gostava eu a desse tamanho
grande para fazer ginástica olímpica
eu fiz muito com o desenho eu fiz de
tudo assim estudava tudo fora do padrão
curricular comum eu acho que isso me
ajudou muito agregou porque eu queria
falar tanto é que você pode até não
acreditar mas eu sou muito tímido se
vocês forem falar comigo pessoalmente
não vê que eu fico bem assim mas eu não
tenho problema em falar em cima de um
palco por exemplo eu não tenho eu fiz
curso de locução por exemplo uma coisa
que não me preparar pra nada mas eu
achava interessante vai trabalhar como
todo mundo eu fui me formei em design
gráfico depois que eu saí da escola
só que eu não sabe aquela questão o
antigo o que vai me ajudar neste
trabalho nesse curso vai ser mais a
forma de trabalhar do que o título e
tudo bem se eu sei que estou falando
isso na puc né
mas eu não fui buscar o diploma e está
tudo bem assim eu acho que o que vale
mais pra você é fazer o que você que é o
conhecimento agregado que você precisa
não no curso de faculdade eu não aprendi
a mexer com vídeo eu aprendi a mexer com
a imagem é coisa que me ajudou muito mas
por exemplo não sabe comunicar direito
sabe mas mas não bem aí eu fui procurar
um curso de locução o que para tentar
tirar um pouco do meu sotaque mas na
verdade isso piorou as coisas que o
pessoal gostava mesmo é do meu sotaque
então eu comecei assim deitar em cima
disso aí
e fora isso procurei vários cursos por
exemplo formei em design de jogos
eu formei fui pro ceará fazer um curso
de francês que vinha com para fazer o
pneu é um absurdo do brasil com o egito
ali no final das contas tudo foi
agregando pra que no final das contas o
que eu queria fazer que era montar minha
meu próprio negócio desse certo
mas aí o dia que eu vi avó pela creta
mesmo foi o dia que eu cheguei aqui eu
ri é uma história muito engraçada que eu
fui fazer uma entrevista de emprego que
até então trabalhava lá né
ganhava os dois mil e duzentos reais
como designer gráfico estava todo feliz
a irmãzinha renato e queremos chamar
para uma entrevista de emprego e você
vai ganhar três mil reais de salário foi
o que ele me pagar 3.000 vou largar tudo
eu tenho que ir lá fazer a entrevista
quando chegou a fazer essa entrevista
sabe quando você entra sabe aquela que
todo mundo pessoal em baia sentadas em
cada um com seus post assim no
computador zinho a casas bahia divisória
assim você não consegue enxergar muito o
que está acontecendo do lado aquele frei
de burle hora que eu olhei nossa senhora
mas eu não vou agüentar trabalhar que
não ainda bem que eu não passei eu uso
como desculpa mas tudo bem
não passei na entrevista mas regedor
graças a deus que eu passei na
entrevista que talvez isso me segurar se
porque a coisa da estabilidade conta
muito principalmente no país que a gente
tá né
todo mundo procura estabilidade é
difícil pensar um pouco fora da caixa e
querer que as coisas vão nevão além
beleza mas eu só conta um pouco da
história vocês verem como é que eu
cheguei agora vamos falar um pouco sobre
o trabalho do youtube mesmo o que faz o
youtube que a net assim alguém acha que
o youtube não trabalha porque ela só
assim em gente tudo bem recebe hoje um
negócio aqui uma caixa cheia de ouro e
etc
não é assim muito bem que funciona
o primeiro trabalho pro youtube tem
várias métricas e várias coisas mas o
primeiro princípio é escolher um bom
tema um tema que seja um bom jesus nossa
senhora é bonita mas falei certa mas foi
bonito o negócio que vai é e enxergar as
pessoas a clicar no que está falando
porque não adianta nada se tem o melhor
conteúdo do mundo saber sobre tudo mas
não saber passar isso não tenho
interesse da pessoa que vai ficar depois
levar isso pra tudo todas as áreas por
exemplo disso é um pouco de área de
publicidade jornalismo de tudo então é
uma outubro uma grande mma do negócio
neve junto às artes todas bons títulos
porque aquele negócio é quem vai comprar
o jornal se a matéria de capa não foi do
interesse de ninguém vai querer usar
esse produto ou clicar em publicidade
nisso entender o seu público o engraçado
meu público é o seguinte é porque todo
mundo que está no youtube normalmente
pensa assim a as criancinhas vêm falar
com você
nem todo mundo se criancinha e tal mas o
meu público é sempre assim com cada bar
badham assim há 30 anos
ou a minha família adora o seu canal
ouço muito do seu conteúdo porque o fato
de um conteúdo mas mais dos anos 90 anos
80 com conteúdo histórico então assim
não é um conteúdo que normalmente o
youtube é conhecido por pegar né
além de estudo a gente tem o estúdio
roteiro então assim tem muita pesquisa
tem muita organização ea gente tem que
fazer isso de acordo com algumas
métricas do que o youtube também passa
pra gente tem toda uma análise de de
resultado de tudo e tem a parte visual
né gente porque você tem que há o seu
vídeo lá se eles viram um primeiro vídeo
que eu fiz mas o negócio vai evoluir
você precisa de vinheta de abertura
desses de artes cg todos nomes em que
aparecem que nos traz coisa então tem
que ter uma comunicação visual
o design ajudou muito nisso mas não é
talvez a coisa que eu teria estudado
diretamente na faculdade então é sempre
bom e atrás eu sou rato de de conteúdo
no youtube de curso tudo que é curso
pago nos recursos sempre estou estudando
isso aí se esta parte tem a parte de
edição normalmente por exemplo um vídeo
do meu canal demora mais ou menos uma
semana para ficar pronto e tem mais ou
menos de 19 a 21 minutos
mais ou menos assim então assim dá um
trabalho porque é uma semana de roteiro
é uma semana de edição e eu tenho que
pensar o que vai ser porque cib seleção
faça esse processo todo e no final das
contas ele não dá certo o pessoal não
curte é um trabalho perdido né
então tem muita muita treta e tem a capa
do vídeo por exemplo eu sei que todo
mundo aqui no final de semana tá nem
todo mundo que é ao invés de sair fica
lá no netflix escolher o filme impõe 35
finalista vai ser assistido no final das
contas
e por que você escolheu mente um filme
pelo título você escolhe pela capa
também nesta capa eo filme deve ser ruim
sabe não tem o selton mello o selton
mello acho que é muito bom e então isso
funciona na casa no youtube também se
acaba não foi chamado tiva seu conteúdo
não vai valer de nada mesmo que seja o
senhor dos anéis no youtube aquele
melhor vídeo de todos não vai adiantar
nada de 8 é a análise de resultados
porque se você fizer o vídeo beleza
lançou então mas e aí você vai ver que o
vídeo deu certo como não tem como se
pensassem eu acho que deu certo em toda
a américa
o resultado então se você quer fazer
alguma coisa a gente eu quero
infelizmente quero falar que a
matemática é bem importante nossa
senhora aprendeu a ler gráfica isso tudo
é bem importante mesmo é o nono é
inovação porque e além do do youtube já
são 11 uma plataforma sem totalmente
diferente fora da curva
você também tem que inovar não adianta
nada ficar preso seu próprio conteúdo
sempre porque uma hora o pessoal vai
cansar se você não tiver medo de
arriscar a cada dia se vai ficar para
trás porque a tecnologia muda assim
beleza mas aí vamos falar agora um pouco
sobre a parte do dos mimos que todo
mundo recebe porque todo mundo ria segue
ao iniciar a greve que eu vejo assim
gente eu vim almoçar no colo de bluff
islã que ele é um super do sul que então
agradecendo o pessoal aqui
engraçado que muita gente pensa que isso
é uma coisa assim tipo exemplo que nos
aguarde graça lá é porque quer ganhar e
tem dinheiro pra pagar o negócio mas o
negócio é a gente pensar como isso pode
atribuir valor a coisa por que lembre o
youtube as redes sociais são um negócio
de o que pode ser usado
vocês acham que a pessoa que vai se vai
almoçar lá vai mostrar o conteúdo que
ela está fazendo ela não vai gerar mais
engajamento ou gerar que mais pessoas em
quadra o bar banda assim é pra lá comer
aquele prato bonito que ele viu eu sou
muito 5 hamburgo e alguém mostra um bug
no histórico assim continuar forte eu
fico doido tem que lá pra cá o meu
negócio
então assim um influenciador tem muito
mais poder do que ele acha e isso é uma
coisa que você pode pensar pra tudo não
só para o youtube tem porque muita gente
quer fazer um tipo de negócio muita
gente entra com esse tipo e se essa
empreendimento nas redes sociais porque
é hoje o que vende
então assim aprender a dominar essas
técnicas todas é muito importante
ai ai ai todo mundo pergunta mas renato
começou no canal no youtube ou eu tô com
o totonegócio abrir um curso de inglês
eu queria uma dica pra processo pode dar
para a gente ajudar isso aí foi só a
primeira dica é assim entendeu eu também
que o chão e eu também
todo mundo que compartilham conteúdo ou
que compartilham de uma idéia parte do
eu também prefiro aquele show de stand
up também por exemplo caso assim o gent
outro dia eu estava no ônibus sabe
quando está tudo cheio tem um cara que
ela não lava o braço mas não é realmente
tem eu sempre vejo um cara assim é o
negócio da identificação então eu também
vi eu também já passei por isso essa
situação então assim quando eu falo meu
canal sobre nostalgia por exemplo fala
assim gente adorava aquele gostinho de
ser lá de farinha láctea quando fazia
assim pensa nossa senhora eu também
nossa é muito bom a gente olha esse
conteúdo aqui eu gostava também de
farinha láctea
eu gostava muito disso então ó principal
dica que eu dou é forme o que for que
você for fazer forma uma comunidade
nisso forma uma coisa que as pessoas se
identifiquem para elas falarem disso
também sejam sei lá vão montar um
sanduíche ou vão mentir vou falar uma
palavra passe uma pastelaria por exemplo
se você tem uma pastelaria o que todo
mundo acha disso que um pastel ruim
aquele que vem cheio de eventos dentro
né
se eu saísse por exemplo você sabe o que
eu passei deixei dentro do débito a
pastel que tem cheio de s
lá é muito ruim pois é o meu aqui é isso
é aquilo então tornar-se santos é essa
sensação de comunidade uma coisa ao seu
favor e agora pergunta vocês
então será que o youtube ou o youtube dá
trabalho ou não dá né reflexão agora pra
vocês muito obrigado pessoal
[Aplausos]